[Music]
what's up this is chef raw what it do
baby memorial day is coming up and you
know i love to grill now i'm gonna show
you how to get that all-american
barbecue feel right from your stovetop
using the lodge cast-iron reversible
grill we're going to be making raspberry
chipotle chicken thighs lemon pepper
sweet corn smoked pappy potatoes and
charred broccolini this is one of the
top cooking gadgets on amazon and i
thought i'd try it out for you guys so
we want to see if it works if it's worth
buying and if it gives you that real
barbecue taste you know let's get
started we're going to start with our
smoked pappy potatoes so we're going to
start by cutting them into wedges just
like you had growing up you know potato
wickers and we're going to go and boil
these
all right next we got the charred
broccolini super simple all we have to
do is blanch these which means dump them
in boiling water for about three minutes
and then
cold water most people do ice cold water
but i like to save my ice for my
beverages so it's just cold water all
right so our broccolini is over there
chilling and now we're going to do our
raspberry chipotle chicken all right
we're going to mix together all our dry
ingredients we got
garlic powder onion powder and paprika
y'all know how much i love paprika
a little salt and pepper
all right now time for some serious
business
so we got some olive oil
over that on there and now some of the
spices make sure i get all up in there
save some then we're going to season the
[ __ ] out of this chicken
the longer you let this sit the better
it's going to taste i mean you could
even do this the night before i'm gonna
add the rest of this seasoning when i
tell you your memorial day is about to
be poppin
man put this to the side
and now for the sauce and when i tell
you the sausage fire is fire since we
can't go outside and get that charcoal
feel we're going to introduce some
ingredients to give you that smoky and
really really charred taste so we're
going to start by adding some butter
once that's melted we're going to add
our raspberries
and we're going to let this cook until
the raspberries start to break down and
when this cooks down it's going to
really just give you give you a really
really great flavor you know summertime
you think berries you think fresh
ingredients this right here is
definitely going to give you that pop of
freshness now we're going to add our dry
ingredients
we got some brown sugar
the chipotle seasoning and that's going
to give you a little bit of spice not
too much just so just a little bit to
kick it up a notch and give you a little
more of that that smoky flavor that
we're looking for then we're going to
add garlic and onion powder
all right so we're going to add in some
ketchup which is going to be the base of
the sauce to kind of tone down that's
the sourness of the raspberries i was
going to puree a bell pepper to get that
sauce but i'm lazy don't feel like doing
it so we're going to use ketchup today
and i know everybody has ketchup right
we're not done yet though this right
here this liquid smoke this is mesquite
liquid smoke this is our secret
ingredient
liquid smoke is really good is what's
going to give you that that barbecue
taste you know since we don't let the
charcoal we're going to add it in right
there last but not least i'm going to
add some more salt and pepper mmm see
this you sometimes just got a waft
you just gotta waft this smell just so
you can use this bask of the ambiance
we're basking and we're basking ladies
and gentlemen boys and girls the moment
you've all been waiting for this large
cast iron grill is now hot we're going
to season these potatoes and we're going
to get started all right got the smoked
paprika because you you know smoked
pappy baby some salt pepper we're going
to give it a little quick little mix now
we're going to add some olive oil to the
potatoes so the seasoning sticks
season generously that way the potatoes
are nice and coated give it that nice
little red
color so before you grill you want to
make sure you grease your grill
but you want to make sure you open the
uh spray bottle unscrew that
oh
we add the potatoes i'll put them on
their diagonal so you get those cool
grill marks on there you know i feel
like i feel like i'm grilling right now
you know i got you know i i got ashy
feet
i got my my chocolates on you know
that's how you know every barbecue you
got that old man on the grill
if they if their feet aren't at least a
little bit ashy then they don't know
what they're doing clearly they don't
know what they're doing all right we can
go ahead and give these a flip see what
they look like
oh yeah look at those grill marks look
at that
that's nice potatoes are done oh look at
that look at them yo this thing right
here
don't do anything right to put some
grill marks on there we're gonna add a
little more olive oil and we're going to
dust it with a little more of this
smoked paprika
and a little bit of parsley
just get a little more pop of freshness
and a little color contrast potatoes
done time to get the broccolini on we're
going to start by adding a little bit of
olive oil and then we're just going to
put a little bit of cumin salt pepper
and now we're going to add it to the
grill we're just going to put it on
there long enough just to get a nice
char on there you want to feel a little
bit of burntness
i also like to do all of my vegetables
first
just in case you have some vegetarians
you know don't want their food to be
meaty
there it is
nice little char exactly we're looking
for right there all right two out of
four done i'm going to grill some of
this lemon we'll add a little bit of
sugar
on both sides because the sugar is
what's going to caramelize and give it
those beautiful grill marks
look at them grill marks
so far so good another thing i like
about this is there's like a little like
drip tray over here on the side to kind
of catch all of the extra stuff or
juices that may fall off a lot of grills
don't have stuff like that so this is a
win for me i'm really feeling good about
this this stovetop grill is really
giving me that you know that barbecue
feel so uh well let's go ahead and add
the corn now
first we're going to zest some of this
lemon into the butter then we're going
to add lemon pepper
make sure your butter is soft so you can
mix it in real easy and then you can
spread it over top of the corn
add the corn to the grill
the side that you buttered
oh no that's smoking
i got smoke in my face it's hot this is
like a barbecue for real so we're going
to take the corn off we'll add a little
bit more of this butter to the top of it
and a little bit of parsley
and there you go corn is done
all right guys the moment we've all been
waiting for time for the chicken
there's nothing more satisfying than
putting something on the grill and
hearing that sizzle get chills
so so far this is pretty much the best
experience you're going to get in the
house barbecue
here is definitely the moment when you
grab yourself a beer put on some music
and just really kind of you know
kind of start to feel yourself a little
bit you know you gotta
gotta feel it
do a little dance not too much though
now we're gonna give it a little flip
oh
jermaine you have done it again that boy
good
oh that boy good this is this grill hey
man
i don't think i would have got better
grill marks on the grill actually to be
honest with you it's time to bring in
the flavor i'm going to add some of our
sauce to the other side that we just
grilled go ahead and baste it on there
oh man this is going to be so good
so you want to flip them again
baste the other side you see all that
that sauce just kind of caramelized
right on top of there
a veteran move is very risky very
dangerous
but uh grab one of these things
oh yeah
you know i'm pretty good at this got the
chipotle pepper give it a little a
little bit of heat at the end
you taste the freshness of the
raspberries man this is this is good
i'm going to add a little more parsley
and that's it it's done
now the only thing left is to plate it
up and eat
let's go and give this thing a try
whoa
yo
just right here
oh my gosh people gonna be so happy so
there's no real replacement for cooking
on a charcoal grill but this is pretty
damn close i'm not gonna lie i'm pretty
impressed with the stovetop grill this
is this is a barbecue i'm really
surprised it did as well as it did but i
gotta say i give it two thumbs up
let me know in the comments if there's
any other gadgets you want me to try out
when i make it happen i'm jermaine
rawlings and
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you